und jetzt weiter nach Düsseldorf die
Vorsitzende des
bundestagsverteidigungsausschusses
agnesstrak Zimmermann von der FDP ist
uns zugeschaltet schönen guten Morgen
guten Morgen
ihr Parteikollege Frau Zimmermann
Alexander Lamsdorf und sie auch haben
sich wir Twitter quasi frühzeitig auf
eine russische Verantwortung festgelegt
haben den Tweet inzwischen zwar gelöscht
wir leben ja in Zeiten jetzt von Fake
News von Fakten Umkehr sie sind
Vorsitzender des
Verteidigungsausschusses bereuen Sie
diesen Tweet
nein ich bereue gar nicht richtig ist
oder andersrum dass die Quelle eine
andere Aussage hatte deswegen habe ich
reagiert als ich hörte das ist nicht so
das gehört dazu habe ich es gelöscht und
gerade gerückt ich glaube das ist das
Minister was man tun kann aber ich
möchte darauf hinweisen dass es mir
wichtig dass wir hier nicht die Opfer
zum Täter oder Täter zu Opfern machen
Ukraine ist von 90 in wenigen Stunden
nach der Abreise des russischen
Außenministers aus Bali von 90 Gruß
Michaels und Raketen flächendeckend
angegriffen worden allein in dem Raum
Lewis sind 15 Raketen runtergegangen und
dann hat die Ukraine sich entsprechend
gewehrt das ist die Realität und das
sollte man jetzt nicht aus dem Auge
verlieren
dieser Vorfall der verdeutlicht
jedenfalls wie unglaublich schnell die
Dinge eskalieren können Minuten nach dem
Vorfall stand ja die Frage im Raum
befindet sich die NATO befinden wir uns
damit aktiv im Kriegsgeschehen Gott sei
Dank sind alle besonnen geblieben was
lehrt uns jetzt dieser Vorfall
also ist eine Blaupause dafür dass es
richtig ist besonnen ist wir können uns
ja vielleicht ist das auch ein Signal an
alle dass dieser Krieg uns alle etwas
angeht er findet nämlich vor unserer
Haustüre statt er findet im Grenzgebiet
zu Polen statt und das ist nur wenige
Stunden von Berlin entfernt und das ist
deswegen von großer Bedeutung ist für
die die glauben dass wir im Warmen
sitzen und nichts damit zu tun haben
dass wir an der Seite der Ukraine stehen
dass wir sie neben humanitär und
wirtschaftlicher Hilfe eben auch
militärisch weiter unterstützen und dass
die Situation eben sehr ernst ist aber
ich glaube gerade angesichts des
Verhaltens übrigens auch das polnischen
Staates der ja sehr besonnen war dass in
der NATO überhaupt keiner Interesse hat
dass es zu einer Eskalation kommt dass
wir aber davon ausgehen müssen dass
Russland weiter die Ukraine übersät mit
Bomben mit Raketen weiter mordet und
deswegen werden und sollten wir weiter
an der Seite der Ukraine ohne Wenn und
ohne aber stehen
wenn wieder eine Rakete auf NATO Gebiet
nieder geht das ist ja seit vorgestern
absolut nicht mehr ausgeschlossen
das war nie ausgeschlossen in den neun
Monaten wenn in einem Land wie die
Ukraine wiederhole mich ungern aber in
wenigen Stunden 90 Raketen runterkommen
dann ist das eben nicht ausgeschlossen
aber genau deswegen ist es ja so gut
dass dieses Bündnis aus 30 Staaten bei
32 Staaten natürlich dann auch dorthin
fährt
Amerikaner und polnische Fachleute haben
sich den einschlagplatz da wo die
Menschen tragischerweise ums Leben
gekommen sind genau angeschaut und das
Schwierige ist eben dass es sich bei
diesem bei dieser Rakete eben um eine
sowjetische Bauart gehandelt hat das ist
das Thema dass die Ukraine eben auch
noch altes Material hat und ich habe
großes Verständnis dafür dass die
Ukraine mehr Artillerie braucht und wenn
sie aus westliche Hand kommt dann kann
es da auch keine Missverständnis mehr
geben aber der Wahrheit geschuldet
dieser Krieg ist im Herzen Europas und
zu glauben dass er an der Grenze
sozusagen dass die Bombe praktisch
unmittelbar an der Grenze nicht
runtergehen könnte ist naiv da müssen
wir sein umso wichtiger ist es
hinzuschauen Ruhe zu bewahren
kontrollieren aber nochmal der Täter ist
Wladimir Putin ermordet weiter in der
Ukraine im Großraum Kiew waren die
Menschen um sieben Stunden lang ohne
Strom ohne Wasser ohne Heizung und wir
sollten bei aller berechtigten Aufregung
bitte nicht Täter und Opfer verwechseln
das tun wir hier nicht wir wollen noch
mal fragen zu den Konsequenzen die das
hat im Grunde auch für Deutschland für
die NATO die Polen mit airpolizing
helfen möchte den Luftraum besser zu
schützen und vielleicht aktiv zu
reagieren das hat ja offenbar nicht
geklappt nicht funktioniert was muss
denn Deutschland was die NATO besser bzw
schneller machen
naja das ist ja in einem Kriegsverlauf
immer so dass Dinge geschehen und
natürlich dann das Militär entsprechend
reflektiert was ist passiert wie kann
man sowas verhindern das wird jetzt
passieren und das ist natürlich auch von
großer Bedeutung wenn ich das so sagen
darf learning by doing weil diese Form
des großen Angriffs auf ein europäisches
Land das haben wir in der Form nicht
erlebt vor allen Dingen ein solcher
Überfall haben wir nicht erlebt und
insofern werden die Militärstrategen
sich natürlich jetzt genau damit
beschäftigen wie kann sowas wie kann die
Antwort auf so ein großflächigen Angriff
lauten und wie vor allen Dingen kann man
die Nachbarländer schützen die
unmittelbar eine Grenze zu Ukraine zu
Ukraine haben Agnes stark Zimmermann von
der FDP die Vorsitzende des Bundestags
Verteidigungsausschusses zu dem
Raketeneinschlag in Polen und den Folgen
vielen Dank
ich danke Ihnen